yeah it's uh  very very tempting but i i really want  to highlight that all of white's trouble  started with this pawn on a3 every  everything that all these that he went  all in on the king side with all these  attacks was based on the fact that he  he made this uh  terrible weakness on the queen side with  ac and he couldn't play strategically  positionally calmly  couldn't continue playing calmly and  then if he was forced to to do these  things but  the there there was simply no attack i  mean he he tried to unite this on the  board  he tried to create something from i no  night 21 91 check game over that's it  that's it  the queen has lost it's a beautiful  family fork and that is game over  yeah big win a huge win for for rapport  and it also gives us the chance to move  on i mean uh  let's go to magnus's board because  magnus  let's see has he recovered